der blick gesenkt langsamen schrittes
und umzingelt von polizisten kommt
marcel t zurück zum tatort
es ist der ort an dem der angeklagte vor
wenigen monaten ein blutiges verbrechen
begeht er überfällt einen juwelier und
schlägt ihn brutal nieder besonders
perfide während der tat steht seine
ehefrau mlt mit kinderwagen und säugling
vor der tür schmiere
doch die ehefrau bestreitet vor gericht
die hilferufe und leidens schreie des
opfers gehört zu haben grund für eine
ungewöhnliche beweisaufnahme das gericht
musste die szene nachstellen das heißt
der juli rund ein wachmeister sind in
die räumlichkeiten des juweliers
gegangen haben dort laut geschrien und
diese kampfszene nachgestellt vor der
tür stand dann der richter zusammen mit
seinen beigeordneten und die schöffen
und haben gehört ob sie was hören oder
nicht rückblick hagen in
nordrhein-westfalen oktober 2021 die
aufnahme der überwachungskamera ist
verstörend eine blutlache auf dem boden
daneben zwei männer ineinander verkeilt
es zeigt den vergeblichen versuch des
juweliers ismael sich von marcel tees
brutalen attacken zu wären mindestens 50
mal schlechte angeklagte dem juwelier
mit einer schreckschusswaffe auf den
kopf raubt im anschluss ist mehr us
geschäft aus und die aufnahme zeigt die
ehefrau des angreifers mlt mit einem
kinderwagen vor der tür des juweliers im
kinderwagen schläft das gemeinsame baby
15 minuten dauert der brutale überfall
es mag an blutüberströmt und mit einem
schädelbruch aus seinem laden fliehen
dreifach mama ehefrau und angeklagte mlt
behauptete nun aber dreist im prozess
dass sie zwar komplizin von ihrem
brutalo ehemann war und vor dem
juweliergeschäft schmiere stand doch von
der brutalität ihrer ehemannes habe sie
nichts mitbekommen
israels schreie hätte sie nicht gehört
doch julian fan hahn anwalt des opfers
gibt sich nach der ungewöhnlichen
beweisaufnahme siegessicher ich habe
zugehört ich stand wohl ich denke mal in
der gleichen position wie die mit der
angeklagte gestanden haben soll wie auch
das gericht gerade gestanden hat und ich
habe alles gehört die polizei bringt
marcel t im anschluss zurück in u haft
es warten noch drei weitere
verhandlungstage auf den brutalen
goldräuber seine ehefrau im lte ist auf
freiem fuß sie muss sich um das baby und
die weiteren zwei kinder kümmern